[Music]
Zendaya shows off her manicure and if
you look closely you'll see a sweet and
subtle tribute to her man Tom Holland
it's great to have that support and that
love around you because you need that on
Monday the Euphoria Stars manicure has
shared this clip of her newly done Nails
on Instagram and get ready to cue the Oz
because some eagle-eyed fans were quick
to point out Zendaya's gold ring which
features the initials th I am blown away
but Zendaya isn't the only one rocking
her Love's initials last week the couple
was spotted at the supermarket in London
and Tom had the letter Z stitched on the
back pocket of his pants I appreciated
you know the love that I got so you know
I have no complaints coincidence maybe
but Tom was caught out on a separate
occasion July sporting a similar pattern
I am sweating and get this Zendaya
opened up about her love for knitting in
the past which might explain the
embroidered letter on Tom's pants who
tortured in it oh my my mom taught me to
knit of course the couple is notoriously
private they went public with their love
in 2021 after years of playing koi about
their relationship have you found that
it's hard today in Hollywood so yeah
it's such a young age it is I mean it's
hard to say at any age I mean it doesn't
matter you know where you are either I
mean it's just hard to date in general
you know romance rumors first sparked on
the Spider-Man press tour in 2017. it
happens all the time and of course you
know we we expected it I mean it's
um it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it's all good fast
forward a few years later Tom confirmed
he and Zendaya are a thing and ever
since he hasn't shied away from proving
he's her biggest fan I think Zendaya
just showed up
that's her I want to see what she has on
can we watch is she gonna walk down here
it's her let's watch oh she's going in
she's going in she's gone
so whether it's a red carpet moment a
ring tribute or a letter stitched on the
back of Tom's pants safe to say these
two just keep getting cuter
[Music]
thank you